metro also weighing with an important  reminder as we go through the extreme  temperatures  of the summer months officers say they  rely on you to help them  save lives the public is our eyes and  ears when when a police officer isn't  around  and it's always great when the public  calls when they see  a uh a child or a pet in a in a hot  vehicle the way we respond to those  is uh we'll usually get that call we  encourage people to call 9-1-1 it's a  serious issue  our officers will roll code which is  lights and siren to get to the scene as  immediately as they can  they'll uh will request medical and when  the officers get there we'll assess the  situation  well he says depending on the situation  they'll either break a window or work to  find the  owner of the car he also tells us it's  important to note that leaving your  child  or an animal in a hot vehicle is a crime  and you could have a criminal charge  filed against you